megyn kelly Fox News host megyn kelly's
new memoir is making a lot of news and I
want to sort of look at a couple aspects
of this she says in her upcoming memoir
that president elect Trump often tried
to offer her gifts in exchange for
positive coverage during the 2016
election this is major particularly
because she says that although she
didn't accept any of the gifts there
were journalists who she doesn't name
that accepted gift from Donald Trump the
associated press reported yesterday
about an excerpt from her memoir settle
for more which says that Trump would
give journalists and commentators if
they were willing to talk him up and if
they wanted different gifts including
free airfare free stays at Trump's
various properties let's put up a quote
here from settle for more by megan kelly
this is actually one of the untold
stories of the 2016 campaign i was not
the only journalist to whom trump
offered gifts clearly meant to shape
coverage Trump tried to work the refs
and some of the refs responded this is
smart because the media is full of
people whose egos need stroking saying
that Trump would work with certain TV
hosts also to come up with criticism for
himself so they wouldn't be seen as
being in the tank for Donald Trump but
she says she resisted these offers which
included like a girls weekend at Trump's
downtown Manhattan hotel or flying her
and her husband to his mar-a-lago estate
in Florida one little question that
comes up for me is why on earth is this
an untold story this should have been a
major story during the campaign megan
kelly could have been the hero who went
public with it but i guess going public
with it during the campaign doesn't
benefit her as much as publishing it in
her memoir after the campaign is over
well yeah it's a hush-hush because of
course the journalists aren't going to
reveal that this is what happened
someone should overcome this ethical
conundrum and break the story and she
probably should have done that here yeah
she's emerging now is the most sought
after star and television news and
getting offers for contracts about 20
million and quite frankly even if she
had made this admission before I don't
think it would have changed
no I'm at like we know Trump could shoot
people on Fifth Avenue he could make fun
of disabled people oh he did he could uh
talk about grab by the [ __ ] oh he did
that he could talk about women being
pigs oh he did that as well none of
these things affected him so the fact
that he was trying and apparently
according to megan kelly successfully
bought journalists off would not likely
have changed the election results but it
would have been nice of her to bring it
up and like Trump megyn kelly is a very
smart person who is selling her book she
wants to sell it to the largest number
of people possible left and right and
more than likely she is going to
successfully do that because a lot of
what is in this book is very very
compelling